[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slomker guten Abend
porise könnte der Begriff unserer Zeit
werden die
mehrfachkrise oder anders gesagt Krisen
wohin das Auge reicht im Nahen Osten in
Osteuropa im
Indopazifik Stichwort China und man kann
sich noch reichlich zusätzliche Krisen
und Kriege ausmalen die wie
Schattenspieler hinterm Horizont ihr
hässliches
hauptben vor diesem Hintergrund trafen
sich die Außenminister der G7 die als
Gruppe für sich ein Anspruch nimmt auch
eine Wertegemeinschaft zu sein zumindest
demokratische Gesellschaften zu
repräsentieren denen das Völkerrecht
nicht gänzlich egal ist diese
Außenminister das darf man so sagen
sahen müde aus allen voran der
amerikanische der zwar immer noch eine
Supermacht vertritt die in diesen Zeiten
aber schwer getestet wird Andreas Künast
berichtet bevor man als einer von sieben
Außenministern in den Besprechungsraum
kommt muss man an diesem Schrank vorbei
das ist der G7 Handy schließfachschrank
und das ist das Prinzip von G7 treffen
anders als die allermeisten anderen
Gipfel finden G7 Runden ohne Handys
statt ohne Zeitdruck ohne Tagesordnung
und angeblich ohne Tabus in Tokio denken
die sieben westlichen Außenminister
nicht nur über den Krieg im Nahen Osten
nach sondern auch über einen möglichen
Frieden wer wird Gaza verwalten wer wird
dort leben was soll
geschehen keine Vertreibung der
nicht jetzt und nicht nach dem Krieg
keine Nutzung von Gaza als Plattform für
Terror oder Gewalt keine Wiederbesetzung
kein Versuch Gaza zu blockieren oder zu
belagern und keine Verkleinerung des
Territoriums diese Warnungen wird von
Blinkens Kolleginnen nur eine fast
wortgleich übernehmen die deutsche die
G7 reden lange und offen über das
Dilemma in dem sich Israel befindet und
man gern wer genau bremst und wer genau
drängt aber es darf pro Minister nur ein
Berater mit in den Raum und die
Presse nur ganz ganz kurz am Anfang der
klare Appell von uns als G7 ist daher
deutlich es braucht humanitäre Pausen um
die Menschen in Gaza die so furchtbar
leiden mit dem Nötigsten an Wasser an
Lebensmitteln an medizinischer Hilfe zu
versorgen egal wie sehr das japanische
Protokoll auch drängelt der US
Außenminister lässt sich in jeder noch
so kurzen Sitzungspause sein Handy
wiedergeben blinken hat gerade in Israel
für eine längere Feuerpause geworben
aber das ist auch den G7 zu früh ein
Waffenstillstand also ein pauschaler
Aufruf zur Einstellung der Militäraktion
ist etwas völlig anderes als eine
humanitäre
Pause bei der Verteidigung der Ukraine
hat zwischen die Außenminister kein
Blatt und keine Resolution gepasst beim
Umgang mit Israel dagegen haben die G7
schon in der ersten Abstimmung in der UN
Generalversammlung so unterschiedlich
votiert dass etwa Frankreich und
Deutschland heute ziemlich lange
miteinander brauchten wir sind nicht
mehr gespalten sagt das Foto aber so
richtig einig sind sich die G7 auch
nicht im Bericht gerade schon gehört es
geht nicht um waffenstill Stände die das
Ergebnis langwieriger Verhandlungen und
förmlicher Vereinbarungen der
Kriegsparteien wären sondern es geht um
vorübergehende taktische Feuerpausen die
fordert US-Präsident Biden inzwischen
allerdings sehr nachdrücklich verbunden
auch mit dem Hinweis dies könne helfen
Geiseln frei zu bekommen fragen wir nach
bei Katrin Eigendorf in Tel Aviv Katrin
wie reagiert man in Israel auf diesen
wachsenden internationalen
Druck
also bisher ist die israelische
Regierung weiterhin entschlossen an
ihrer Haltung festzuhalten zu sagen eine
Feuerpause wird es nur dann geben wenn
wirklich alle Geiseln freikommen das
sind 241 Geiseln die sich noch immer in
den Händen der Hamas befinden im Moment
hören wir aus
hamaskreisen dass die Hamas wohl ein
Angebot auf den Tisch gelegt haben soll
wonach 12 Geiseln im Austausch für eine
Feuer Pause von 72 Stunden
möglicherweise freikommen könnten äh das
ist etwas das von den meisten Israelis
sehr kritisch gesehen wird hier hat man
einfach Angst dass jede Form von
Feuerpause wie lange sie auch dauern
möge der Hamas die Möglichkeit gibt sich
wieder zu regruppieren denn im Moment
sieht das israelische Militär sicher im
Aufwind sie sind inzwischen in Gaza
Stadt es ist ihnen gelungen äh Teile der
Infrastruktur der Hamas zu zerstören
jede Form von Feuerpause das ist die
Sicht Israels und das ist auch die Sicht
der Militärs würde diesen Vorsprung im
Prinzip wieder zerstören und die
geiselfamilien also die Angehörigen der
241 Geiseln sehen auch dieses Angebot
teilweise kritisch so hört man
stimmen dass sie sagen wie kann das sein
dass nur ein Teil freikommt was passiert
dann mit den anderen Geiseln also dass
sie auch ein Risiko sehen dass die
freigekommenen äh dann mit dem Leben
davon kommen aber andere möglich Weise
sterben also insgesamt wird diese
Initiative in Israel sehr kritisch
gesehen allerdings habe ich heute auch
mit dem Oppositionsführer hier
gesprochen mit J laped der wiederum
mahnt die Regierung in
Israel zu sehen dass der internationale
Druck wächst und dass man darauf jetzt
auch mal reagieren muss danke Katrin
nach Tel
Aviv 10 Jahre ist es her dass ich in der
Ukraine die Generation euromaidan erhob
auf dem Maidan dem großen zentralen
Platz in Kiev versammelten sich im
November 2013 vor allem junge Menschen
mit der EU-Flagge in der Hand für
ztausende war sie das Symbol für
Aufbruch und es ist kein falscher Patos
zu sagen in diesem Winter auf dem Maidan
starben Menschen auch dafür zu Europa zu
gehören für die euromidan Generation wie
sie in der Ukraine genannt wird scheint
das Ziel zur EU zu gehören zwar immer
noch noch Lichtjahre entfernt aber
immerhin hat sich die Tür heute einen
spaltweit geöffnet die EU-Kommission hat
sich für förmliche
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
ausgesprochen dar Hasan sad hat dazu in
der Ukraine Stimmen für uns
eingefangen auf dem Maidan in Kiev hat
die Ukraine ihren Weg nach Europa
begonnen damals mit dabei volodomir er
demonstrierte für Freiheit aber auch
gegen den russischen Einfluss die Macht
der Oligarchen beschneiden das fordert
die EU heute und bis heute ist das auch
volodimirs Anliegen er litt als
selbständiger unter der kriminellen
Geschäftswelt heute dient er in der
Armee damals wurdest du verfolgt wenn du
dich nicht auf die Diebe eingelassen
hast heute werden die Schurken
verfolgt wenn man sich das vor Augen
führt welchen Weg die Ukraine
zurückgelegt hat welches Momentum
entstanden
ist es ist wirklich
unglaublich mitten im Krieg treibt die
Ukraine tiefgreifende Reformen voran um
EU Kriterien für den Beginn von
beitrittsgesprächen zu erfüllen die
Juristin Olena Sonik berät die Regierung
in justizfragen hat in Jell studiert ist
weit gereist und hat die Ukraine auch im
Krieg nicht
verlassen ich erinere mich wie wir
diewerbung zum kandat
haben überall
Bombenangriffe wir saßen in den Bunkern
und haben diese Dokumente verfasst alles
vorbereitet selbstbewusst zählt Olena
die Fortschritte auf im Kampf gegen
Korruption bei Reformen der
verfassungsjustiz doch es hakt in der
Praxis beispielsweise bei juristisch
fragwürdigen
Bauvorschriften wenn Gesetze großen
Interpretationspielraum
lassen fehlt was verantwortliche zu tun
haben dann entsteht Raum für Bestechung
und Korruption das wichtigste ist wir
brauchen eindeutige Gesetze sie müssen
transparent sein und vor allem weniger
dumme
Vorschriften weniger Bürokratie wird mit
EU-Standards sicher nicht kommen meint
Landwirt Reis der seit 20 Jahren in der
Ukraine arbeitet der Betrieb östlich von
Kiev besteht auf dem Weltmarkt ohne
Subventionen ukrainische Agrarsektor
könnte auch der EU einen Schub geben ja
man hat ein Ziel man bekommt ein Ziel
wann man
eben dass man e beitreten kann man hat
ein Ziel wo man sich hinentwickeln kann
und das ist glaube ich das zugwert das
ist halt wesentlich einfacher irgendwo
hinzugehen wenn man ein Ziel vor Augen
hat als wenn man einfach nur so durch
die Welt läuft ja olodom mir ist wie
viele Ukrainer stolz auf das Erreichte
und weiß doch was vor Ihnen liegt die
Ukraine muss sich von innen reformieren
und an der Front den russischen
Angriffskrieg abwehren sie zahlt dafür
den höchsten
Preis t in der Tat bis zu einem Beitritt
gilt es noch gewaltige Hürden zu
überwinden darüber wollen wir noch mit
unserem europakorrespondenten in Brüssel
sprechen mit Ulf Röller Ulf die er erste
Hürde dürfte ja wohl sein ob die
Regierungen der Mitgliedstaaten
überhaupt zustimmen
Beitrittsverhandlungen aufzunehmen denn
das ist ja jetzt erstmal nur eine
Empfehlung der Kommission
gewesen ja das ist eine Empfehlung der
das war der Kommission heute sehr
wichtig dieses Signal an die Ukraine zu
schicken man weiß hier in Brüssel und
macht sich ein wenig Sorgen dass die
Lage der Ukraine immer schwieriger wird
es findet dort ein abnutzungs und
Stellungskrieg mit den Russen statt vor
allem mit der Ostukraine viele viele
Tote aber militärisch bewegt sich nicht
wirklich etwas in die ein oder andere
Richtung und deshalb wollte man heute
hier von der Kommission dieses Signal
geben dass es bald Gespräche geben kann
quasi eine Motivation pritze man hat das
noch verpackt mit einem Kompliment in
dem vonderlin gesagt hat die
kommissionspräsidentin dass die Ukraine
von den
reformaulagen die man ihr gegeben hat
schon 90% erfüllt hat aber 10 nicht und
diese 10% sollte man nicht unterschätzen
im Dezember jetzt wird es den EU-Gipfel
geben und dann werden die EU
Regierungschefs offiziell entscheiden ob
sie Beitrittsgespräche ob sie
Beitrittsgespräche aufnehmen oder nicht
ich persönlich sage sie werden das
aber eben auch nur weil sie wissen dass
der Beitritt noch sehr sehr lange dauert
und deshalb wollen sie auch bei diesem
sage ich mal inszenierten
motivationsspiel das man der Ukraine
gibt mitmachen nun jetzt selbst wenn es
über Zeit der Ukraine gelingen würde all
diese Reform erfolgreich umzusetzen kann
denn die EU in ihrem jetzigen Zustand
dieses Riesenland einfach so
aufnehmen offiziell kriegt man dazu
keine wirkliche Antwort inoffiziell ist
die Skepsis eben sehr sehr groß dass
eine Aufnahme der Ukraine auch ein
zerstörtes Land nach diesem massiven
Krieg die EU völlig überfordert und vor
allem eben bei dem Thema Agrarsubvention
muss man wissen das ist quasi die
Goldmiene Europas da wollen ganz viele
goldschirfen die Franzosen die Polen die
Deutschen die wollen alle
Agrarsubvention haben und wenn die
Ukraine als dieser riesenagrarstadt in
die EU reinkäme würden eben die Gelder
neu verteilt werden müssen und dann
würde Deutschland Frankreich Polen
Ungarn eben wesentlich weniger Geld
kriegen die Ungarn der Regierungschef
Orban hat schon sehr deutlich gesagt das
wird's mit ihm nicht geben er wird das
also blockieren wenn es wirklich mal
soweit sein sollte also wenn es ums Geld
geht und am Ende geht es eben ums Geld
auch bei diesem Beitritt dann wird doch
die EU und die Regierungschefs sehr
unromantisch und dann sind diese großen
Versprechen von Freiheit und an der
Seite stehen die schmelzen dann ein
bisschen mm romantisches schön gesagt
danke Ulf nach
Brüssel zu diesem wie zu anderen Themen
hält sie auch die ztf heute App immer
auf dem Laufenden die gibt es neuerdings
auch bei Whatsapp dafür scannen Sie
entweder den angezeigten QR-Code oder
sie abonnieren ZDF heute direkt bei
WhatsApp und so bekommen Sie die
Nachrichtenlage immer kompakt
zusammengefasst mit Updates am Morgen
und am
Abend zwei Kriege gleich zeitig vor der
Haustür der EU die auch in unsere
Gesellschaft ja unmittelbar hineinwirken
und mit dem Nahostkrieg befasste sich
heute der Bundespräsident Heinz damit
geht's bei dir jetzt weiter lassen Sie
sich nicht von der Hamas
instrumentalisieren dazu hat
Bundespräsident Steinmeier in
Deutschland lebende Menschen mit
palästinensischen und arabischen Wurzeln
aufgerufen bei einem runden Tisch im
Schloss belvü sagte Steinmeier er
erwarte dass man sich gemeinsam gegen
Terrorismus Wende gegen Volksverhetzung
und gegen den Aufruf zur Vernichtung
Israels eingeladen waren Menschen die
für ein Zusammenleben ohne
Antisemitismus und ohne
muslimfeindlichkeit
stehen an einer Schule in Hamburg haben
am Vormittag zwei unbekannte Jugendliche
einen Klassenraum betreten und mit einer
mutmaßlichen Schusswaffe auf eine
Lehrerin gezielt dann seien sie geflohen
so ein Polizeisprecher ein groß
auffgeburt der Polizei durchsuchte die
Schule zunächst ohne Erfolg bei der
fandung nach einer weiteren
Bedrohungslage wurden vier Schüler im
Alter von 12 bis 14 Jahren festgenommen
zwei augenscheinliche Spielzeugwaffen
wurden
sichergestellt aus Protest blieben viele
Apotheken in Norddeutschland heute
geschlossen auf Kundgebungen forderten
norddeutsche Apothekerinnen und
Apotheker höhere Honorare und
kritisierten die Gesundheitspolitik der
Bundesregierung die Aktionen sind der
Auftakt zu bundesweiten Protesten im
November Bundeskanzler Scholz hat die
vorläufige Absage von cduchef März an
gemeinsame Gespräche zur
Migrationspolitik bedauert das sagte
eine Regierungssprecherin in Berlin die
Hand des Bundeskanzlers werde aber
ausgestreckt bleiben März hatte Scholz
gestern mangelnde
Kooperationsbereitschaft mit der
Opposition
vorgehalten und über das Thema Migration
wurde heute auch im Bundestag beraten in
einer aktuellen kritisierten
Unionspolitiker die jüngsten Beschlüsse
von Bund und Ländern gingen nicht weit
genug etwa beim Familiennachzug und der
Benennung von sicheren
Herkunftsstaaten Rednerinnen der
Regierungsparteien verteidigten die
Beschlüsse deragegend die nun zugig
umgesetzt werden
müssten das Thema an dem sich
Innenminister bzw Ministerinnen beweisen
oder scheitern können wobei die
Handlungsspielräume einzelner
Regierungen dabei ja durchaus begrenzt
sind der migrationsgipfel im Kanzleramt
hat aber Erwartungen geweckt das weiß
auch in Ministerin fer die heute den
Jahresbericht der Bundespolizei
vorstellte eine Art Bestandsaufnahme zur
inneren Sicherheit zu der mit dem Terror
der Hamas noch weitere Herausforderungen
hinzugekommen sind Christiane
hübscher sie schauen jeden Tag tausenden
Fahrern ins Gesicht A17 zwischen Prag
und Dresden bisher gerne genommene
schleus Route zwischen Osteuropa und
Deutschland seit di Wochen kontrolliert
die Bundespolizei hier wer irgendwie
auffällt wird
rausgewunkenuck bei der Bundespolizei
heißt es die stationären Grenzkontrollen
wirken die Aufgriffe von illegalen
Migranten sind seitdem um rund die
Hälfte zurückgegangen wir haben diese
lebensgefährlichen einschleuungshandlung
nicht mehr wo mehrere Personen bis zu 40
Personen in so einen Transporter
eingefärcht sind undter Lebens
prolischen Umständen das haben ja jetzt
hier nicht mehr mehr als 91 000
unerlaubte einreisen zählte die
bundespolizi im vergangenen Jahr 60%
mehr als
2021 über die balkanrout war es sogar
ein Anstieg von
126%. mehr als 18 000 geschleustte
Personen wurden
aufgegriffen und sie wissen dass diese
Zahlen im laufenden Jahren nochmals
übertroffen werden es ist daher wichtig
und richtig dass wir den Einsatz der
Kräfte der Bundespolizei an allen
Grenzen Deutschlands verstärkt haben
gegen irreguläre Migration und für die
Bekämpfung von übelster
schleuserkriminalität es sein fordernde
Zeiten für die Einsatzkräfte beschreibt
der bundespolizeipräsident heute und
sieht doch kurzfristig keine andere
Lösung als Grenzkontrollen was wir nicht
machen ist die Grenze schließen an
keiner Stelle wir kontrollieren an den
Grenz die
Alternative wäre ein wehrlos es
unterlassen das kommt nicht in Frage die
Sicherheitslage insgesamt sei angespannt
in Deutschland so die
bundesinnenministerin tausende
Polizisten müssen dieser Tage immer
wieder eskalierende Demonstrationen
absichern vor 5 Tagen wurde in essenar
die Ausrufung eines Kalifats gefordert
der Innenminister von Nordrheinwestfalen
wendet sich daraufhin heute per Brief an
Nancy fer und warnt vor drei neuen
islamistischen Gruppierungen mit
erheblichem Mobilisierungspotenzial
ich Ford dass die Organisation die wir
da benennen vielleicht gibt's noch mehr
geprüft werden und am besten verboten
werden ich forder von uns selber dass
wir bei den Plakaten und Texten noch
sorgfältiger hinschauen Steine Böller
Flaschen die auf Polizistinnen und
Polizisten geworfen werden 700 verletzte
Beamte zählt die Bundespolizei fürs
letzte Jahr das heißt jeden Tag im
Dienst werden zwei Beamte von uns
vorsätzlich verletzt ihr Einsatz ih ih
verstärkten Kontrollen bringen aber auch
einen Beifang mit sich 19000 offene
Haftbefehle konnten erfolgreich
vollstreckt werden so viele wie nie
zuvor dazu gibt es nachher im heute
journal Update noch ein Gespräch mit
Sebastian Fiedler dem früheren
Vorsitzenden des bundesdeutscher
Kriminalbeamter und jetzt befassen wir
uns noch mit der Frage wie es
Deutschland wirtschaftlich geht die
Mitglieder des Sachverständigen Rats die
berühmten Wirtschaftsweise
haben sich dazu heute geäußert und man
kann daraus wie diverse Medien zeigen
sehr unterschiedliche Schlagzahlen
formulieren mal heißt es Wirtschaft
schrumpft mal heißt es Wirtschaftsweise
erwarten leichte Erholung beides ist
richtig in diesem Jahr geht es noch mal
leicht bergab fürs nächste Jahr sehen
die Prognosen etwas hoffnungsvoller aus
aber auch nicht rosig britter Bucholz
mit den
Einzelheiten es ist ein ohntes Bild für
das der Kameramann spezielle
Regieanweisung gibt ja wir sehen die
hinteren Herren
nicht genau ist do
sch Jahrzehnte lang war das Bild ein
anderes vor allem Herren beurteilten die
wirtschaftliche Lage Deutschlands nun
ein Novum gleich drei Professorinnen auf
dem Podium doch nach wie vor sind es
gerade Frauen in Deutschland die z.B
Altersarmut erleben das Gremium empfehlt
der Politik ein denken und fordert ein
wirklich ankommen im 21 Jahrhundert
Frauen zu ermächtigen für sie selbst zu
sorgen dafür aber auch die
Voraussetzungen zu haben eben indem die
entsprechende Kinderbetreuung zur
Verfügung gestellt wird indem sie
steuerlich nicht benachteiligt werden
wenn Sie sich beruflich engagieren die
Perspektive insgesamt eher düster
Deutschland sehen Sie in leichter
Rezession in diesem Jahr sei ein
Rückgang der Wirtschaftsleistung um 0,4
zu erwarten im kommenden Jahr eine
leichte Erholung mit einem schwachen
Wachstum von
0,7%. der Nahostkonflikt hat ihnen
zufolge bislang keine größeren
Auswirkungen auf die Weltwirtschaft aber
was wir beobachten ist dass wenn es
aninanderkettung von Krisen gibt das
Konsumentenvertrauen langfristig
gedämpft sein kann das ist von
inflationsperspektive die Sie gerade
Ansprachen gar nicht mal so schlecht ja
da werden die Preise nicht hochgrieben
aber natürlich ist es für das
Wirtschaftswachstum sehr wenig ideal
wenig ideal auch dieses junge müssten
länger arbeiten sie nennen keine
konkrete Zahl doch die steigende
Lebenserwartung müsse berücksichtigt
werden für die nächsten 15 Jahre durch
den Renteneintritt der Babyboomer
verschlechtert sich bei uns die Relation
zwischen denjenigen die z.B das
gesetzliche Rentensystem finanzieren und
denjenigen die dort Leistung erwarten
sehr stark die Politik hat das Thema in
den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen
schleifen lassen ein Ausweg der Ökonomen
selbst vorsorgen z.B mit der aktienrente
das prüft die Ampel gerade die
Opposition fordert dagegen weniger
Regulierung unsere Wirtschaft steht
massiv unter Druck und damit auch
Deutschland denn nur das was wir
verdienen können wir auch für
Sozialstandards z.B ausgeben und deshalb
braucht die Wirtschaft jetzt eine
Bundesregierung die an ihrer Seite steht
und die sie nicht noch mit Hürden
bekämpft die Bundesregierung nimmt
traditionell das Gutachten entgegen die
Aussichten sind mau auch durch die Krise
und Kriege wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
wir jetzt wieder auf die Spur kommen und
die Wachstumsprozesse voranbringen neue
Zeiten ohne Reform wird Deutschland die
Wachstumsschwäche nicht
überwinden und mit Wirtschaft geht's bei
dir jetzt auch weiter he die Kommerzbank
hat Zahlen vorgelegt zum bisherigen
Geschäft in diesem Jahr und auch einen
Ausblick auf die weitere Perspektive
gegeben der Kurs der Kommerzbank Aktie
ging erst nach oben dann nach unten dann
dann wieder aufwärts Frank betmann wie
erklärt sich dieser Kursverlauf na
zunächst mal hat die Bank die
Erwartungen beim Gewinn übertroffen
profitiert vor allem wieder vom
klassischen Bankgeschäft ein Ergebnis
der Zinswende gibt den Sparern also
weniger Zinsen als man selbst für
Kredite verlangt und so verdient das
Geldhaus im dritten Quartal mehr als
dreimal so viel wie vor Jahresfrist
umgehend kletterte der Aktienkurs am
Morgen in Höhen die er seit Monaten
nicht mehr gesehen hatte und da haben
sich die Anleger gesagt guter Zeitpunkt
zum Verkaufen Kursgewinne mitnehmen die
Aktie gab wieder nach dabei sehen die
Zahlen gut aus nach 9 Monaten hat die
Kommerzbank nun bereits 1,8 Milliarden
Euro verdient und strebt für das
Gesamtjahr einen Rekordgewinn von 2,2
Milliarden Euro an mehr noch sie kündigt
an in 2027 3,4 Milliarden Euro verdienen
zu wollen die Botschaft dahinter klar
wir sind keine Krisenbank mehr davon
sollen auch die Aktionäre profitieren
2024 will die kommererzbank mindestens
70% ihrer Gewinne an die Anteilseigner
ausschütten das freut insbesondere den
Bund er ist seit der staatlichen Rettung
in der Finanzkrise
2008 größter Aktionär der Kommerzbank
hält gut 15% der Aktien Frank betmann
vielen Dank
gerne dieses Jahr könnte das wärmste
seit
125 000 Jahren werden das hat der EU
klimawandeldienst Kopernikus errechnet
der Oktober sei nun der fünfte Monat
infolge ind dem der jeweilige höchste
Wert seit Beginn der Aufzeichnungen im
Jahr 1940 gemessen wurde damit läge die
globale Temperatur dieses Jahr derzeit
1,43° CS über dem vorindustriellen
Durchschnitt und was die globale
Erhitzung für die Eismassen der
Polarregionen bedeutet dazu gleich mehr
von östtin terli im Wetterbericht ein
Ergebnis aus der Fußball Champions
League vom vierten Spieltag Union Berlin
hat beim SSC Neapel unentschieden
gespielt 1 Z ein stand es am Ende und
alle Spiele alle Tore dann von 23 Uhr an
in unserer highlightsendung und jetzt
die Zahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewehr 1 12 18 34
39 48 Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf . zdfde und im ZDF Text
auf Seite
557 die Erde ist der Menschheit
bekanntlich nicht genug und wer ein
Global Player sein will also nicht nur
irgendeine Mittelmacht oder
Regionalmacht wie es im Jargon der
internationalen Politik heißt wer mehr
sein will der muss in den Weltraum
jahrzehntelang war das ja Amerikanern
und den Sowjets bzw Russen vorbehalten
inzwischen mischen auch noch andere mit
Indien etwa schickte letztens
erfolgreich eine Sonde auf den Mond die
vierte Nation der das gelungen ist nach
der Sowjetunion den USA und China china
hat natürlich längst ein umfangreiches
Weltraumprogramm wie sich das für eine
aufstrebende Weltmacht gehört
einschließlich bemannter Flüge ins All
unsere Korrespondentin Elisabeth Schmidt
wurden jetzt Einblicke gewährt in die
weltraumpläne der
Volksrepublik
unsere Reise zum chinesischen
Raumfahrtzentrum tiutian beginnt vor
Sonnenaufgang in der Wüste
gobi00 km westlich von Peking ringsum
militärisches
Sperrgebiet westliche Medien bekommen
hier nur selten Einblicke Tian hat die
Dimension einer Kleinstadt hier werden
Chinas taikonauten trainiert
tangungbo fliegt bereits zum zweiten Mal
zur chinesischen Raumstation innerhalb
von nur Z Jahren china macht Tempo
verkürzt die Rotation seiner
Raumfahrer bei meinem ersten Flug
schaute ich immer wieder aus dem Fenster
zur Erde das war sehr emotional das
einst verarmte und geschwächte China ist
heute der hellste und schönste Ort auf
dem
Planeten die Raumfahrt großer Stolz der
Kommunistischen Partei das Team der 17
Mission ist das jüngste das China den
Orbit geschickt hat die taikonauten
sollen die erste außenreparatur an der
Raumstation tiengong zu deutsch
himmelspalast durchführen er soll in den
nächsten Jahren erweitert werden von
seiner te auf eine
Kreuzform wir planen außerdem bald den
Start des Weltraumteleskops hüchen soll
mit der Raumstation in Umlauf gebracht
werden und eine großflächige Vermessung
des Himmels vornehmen das
Weltraumteleskop soll ein 300 Mal
größeres Sichtfeld haben als das von
NASA und ESA entwickelte Hubbel Teleskop
China gelang bereits als einziger Nation
die Landung auf der Erd abgewandten
Seite des Mondes schickte einen Rover
zum Mars und will jetzt eine
Forschungsstation auf dem Mond bauen
Wettrennen im All zwischen zwei
Supermächten die USA schlossen die
Chinesen 2011 von der Internationalen
Raumstation ISS aus wegen
Sicherheitsbedenken ich denke dass das
nicht richtig ist wir sollten
zusammenarbeiten natürlich mit mit aller
Vorsicht insbesondere was
Technologietransfer angeht aber es ist
einfach Zeit wir sind dieser kleine
Planet Erde ist so
schützenswert dass wir besser
zusammenarbeiten auch in der
Raumfahrt die Zeit läuft ab zumindest
für die ISS sie soll gegen 2030 in
Ruhestand gehen zu dem Zeitpunkt zu dem
China seine Mondlandung plant tiong wird
dann die einzige Raumstation im All sein
auf der Erde werden Chinas taikonauten
bereits vor ihrem Abflug als
Nationalhelden gefeiert sechs Monate
wird die shenjo 17 Crew im All neue
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse sammeln
und Chinas Weltraumprogramm weiter
vorantreiben das war's von uns im
auslandjournal geht's gleich weiter mit
Reportagen aus dem Nahen Osten und der
Ukraine und um 0:45 meldet sich dann
Christopher wehmann mit unserem heute
Schal Update und wir melden uns morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die globale
Erhitzung und ihre Folgen für die
Polarregionen darum geht es ab heute auf
einem polarkongress in Paris schauen wir
auf die Antarktis sie ist nicht nur mit
Eis bedeckt sondern auch von Ries
Eisplatten dem Schelfeis umgeben im
Westen schmilzt dieses Schelfeis seit
rund 25 Jahren rasant da diese Eismassen
im Meerwasser liegen wirkt sich ihr
abschmelzen nicht so stark auf den
Meeresspiegel aus aber sie bilden eine
eisige Schutzmauer für die Gletscher auf
dem Kontinent stützen und halten sie
schmilzt das Schelfeis bewegen sich
ganze Gletscher Richtung Ozean und
schmelzen im wärmeren Wasser mit
massiven Auswirkungen auf den Meeres
Spiegel in der Westantarktis ist es laut
Forschenden nicht mehr zu
stoppen kommen wir vom Klima zum Wetter
und da haben wir es mit neuem Regen zu
tun der von Nordwesten ins Land zieht
und den Bändern nach Osten wandert und
das ist auch schon in der Nacht der Fall
im Nordwesten kommt Regen auf nach Süden
ist es eher trocken und hier wird's am
kältesten Temperaturen bis
3° ganz im Süden und 10° im Westen
morgen dann der Regen der über das Land
zieht am ehsten noch Sonnenschein nach
Südosten Richtung Bayern bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 13° im Osten und 7° an
den Alpen und die nächsten Tage sehen
recht wechselhaft aus am Freitag 6 bis
11° und am Sonntag 4 bis 9 ein schönen
Abend